fast schon im jahr 2003 diesen
schwerverbrechern trotz
diskussionen wie diese menschen die kaum
noch zu erreichen sind immer wieder ist
auch das teil des alltags von ärzten und
ärzten wie von dr tarik asis
doch er will etwas dagegen tun gemeinsam
mit seinem kollegen dr aschraf impfen
sie nun im einkaufszentrum klären auf
sie wollen für alle da sein
unkompliziert soll es ab laufen auch
wenn jemand kein deutsch spricht
ich kann keine einwilligungserklärung
wird sich die außerirdischen steht es
gar nicht das muss mir jemand erklären
ich hatte den vorteil dass sich die
sprache sprechen
niemand soll hier scham empfinden zu
fragen niedrigschwellig so dass sich
jeder traut
dass diese einwilligungserklärung
bis zu sieben verschiedene sprachen
beherrschen sie im team wichtig in einer
stadt wie frankfurt
der konnte nur von jerry sprechen
es flogen gemacht die normale bei denen
fährt macht und jetzt ist es auch nicht
frankfurt ist einige leute die kein
deutsch sprechen nur englisch und
eigentlich alle mitglieder unseres teams
nicht gut ist ähnlich wie
man versuchen auch die bürokratischen
hürden so gering wie nötig zu halten das
war gerade ein junger mann der keinen
festen wohnsitz hier hat in frankfurt er
umreißt sich die ganze welt und wollte
es eben verlassen und hatte
und ich habe ihnen angeboten
jeder darf kommt spontan auch ohne
termin auch damit hoffen sie noch mehr
menschen zu überzeugen
doch manchmal hilft auch eine gemeinsame
sprache nicht mehr weiter
impfung in den dienst
immer wieder gibt es
auseinandersetzungen mit menschen die
korona leugnen und die impfung ablehnen
weil seine eltern einen konflikt hat
also sowas gibt es natürlich auch es
gibt immer leute die die nicht
erreichbar persönlich denke immer
hoffentlich hinterher nicht krank ja ja
sagt er oder gibt es gar nicht setzt
nach solchen momenten platt drk sie
optimistisch
gespräch wird sich da noch mal gedanken
machen und vielleicht wird er sich den
betrieb nicht noch mal informieren
dranbleiben und informieren das wollen
die beiden ärzte auch mit videos bei
tecdoc du hast dich leider mit krone
angesteckt und möchte nun wissen wann du
in die notaufnahme zu uns solltest eine
transparenz und eigenen erfahrungen
wollen sie fake news im netz begegnen
das medium das die anderen eben nutzen
das können wir eigentlich auch zum
positiven ja dass wir die leute
dementsprechend seien aufklären um das
impfzentrum hier aufzubauen haben sie
sich zwei wochen urlaub vom klinikalltag
genommen abgerechnet über den bund lässt
sich hiermit auch viel geld verdienen
durch das impfen im einkaufszentrum
wollen sie vor allem ansprechbar sein
für die die keine hausarztpraxis haben
wenn sie in eine mall kommen und wie
sich diese im station hier kann ich
direkt die frage die ich heute morgen in
den sozialen medien gelesen habe direkt
dem markt stärken dann würden sie so
machen es geht vor allem darum vertrauen
zu schaffen zuzuhören und das gehörte
auch weiter zu tragen
unser ziel ist es dass leute mit einem
lächeln hier auch wieder raus ging nicht
mit dem gefühl raus gehen jetzt wurde
ich wohne 20 ist und wir gehen sind
einfach nicht weil dieses gefühl tragen
sie mit nach hause morgen sind sie hier
deshalb wieder für alle da